l'hexagone passe donc au vert les cafés
et restaurants peuvent rouvrir depuis ce
matin les écoles et collèges vont
accueillir de manière obligatoire les
élèves à partir du 22 juin emmanuel
macron à tourner donc officiellement la
page du premier acte de la crise du
corona virus lui semblent très
satisfaits de sa gestion de la crise
évoque d'ailleurs une première victoire
est ce vraiment le cas c'est l'objet de
notre face à face ce soir et pour en
débattre nous sommes en direct avec d'un
jeune amar enseignants porte parole cgt
du val de marne dont soir benjamin amar
merci d'être avec nous à ses comptes et
à ses côtés pour en débattre denis
demonpion éditorialiste politique
bonsoir denis demonpion merci d'être
avec nous alors on va commencer par un
sujet qui est cher à benjamin amarin
tous les élèves crèches écoles et
collèges vont reprendre les cours de
façon obligatoire à partir de lundi
prochain
c'est véritablement le retour à la vie
d'avant benjamin on imaginer quelle a
été votre joie en découvrant cette
annonce des manuels micro hier c'est le
jeu là sur la question de l'école
je pense que le prix nobel de
l'incompétence est incontestablement
attribué à la macro ni parce que la
rouvrir l'école pourquoi aller du 22
juin au 3 juillet dans les écoles et les
collèges
honnêtement hochement on est bon je
pense qu on est la risée de tout le
monde occidental on a un gouvernement
qui en réalité court comme un poulet
sans tête
voilà je rappelle qu'en italie en
espagne qui ont été des clusters
similaire à la france eh bien on a
décidé une fois pour toutes de reporter
la rentrée en septembre
le débat était clos et voilà on
s'épargne et au moins ce débat inutile
en france c'est une saga à incroyable et
le dernier le dernier épisode on se
disait conjointe sa mère les choses
étaient bouclés non
allez on va rouvrir les écoles on va
changer de pronos de protocole sanitaire
pour effectivement huit ou neuf jours de
classe écoutez dans les écoles primaires
et les collèges où il va falloir mettre
en place un nouveau protocole alléger je
pense que les gens vont se tirer les
cheveux
mais enfin bon ça prouve encore une fois
je dirais le laval caen dira la
consistance et l'inconséquence de ce
gouvernement
denis demonpion effectivement rouvert
les écoles pour parfois huit jours en
parce que souvent les les enfants n'ont
donc écoles quatre jours ça vous inspire
quoi c'est un bon message qu'on a envoyé
aux français
écoutez j'ai conçu très bien que depuis
ce que vides
la difficulté majeure n'est ce pas
c'était que faire des enfants en
difficulté à l'école s était une bonne
décision de confiner les laisser chez
eux c'est pas certain puisque il ya eu
toute une valse hésitation sur la
l'éventuelle contagion que pouvaient
propager les enfants il s'est avéré au
bout de deux mois que c'était moins
grave est que les enfants n'étaient pas
des vecteurs de contagion aussi sérieux
on l'avait pensé d'abord donc évidemment
il ya eu un tâtonnement mais est-ce que
même le conseil scientifique n'était pas
grand clerc en la matière donc c'est pas
sûr pas non maintenant que les enfants
retournent à l'école aujourd'hui c'est
plutôt bien pourquoi parce que il y en a
beaucoup qui ont des difficultés tous
n'ont pas eu la chance avec le
télétravail des instituteurs de pouvoir
d'ailleurs j'ai des amis instituteurs
qui m'ont dit on en a perdu en deux mois
donc évidemment en une semaine ou quinze
jours ils ne vont pas les rattraper mais
c'est une bonne manière de les ramener
dans le giron de l'école et peut-être de
faciliter la rentrée en septembre
puisque
oui ces chenilles quand même des
vacances benjamin a marre alors on va
faciliter la rentrée en septembre avec
ses deux semaines selon vous que cette
hausse tient également à préciser je
suis enseignant et je suis rentrée dans
l'enseignement pour lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire pour lutter contre
les inégalités scolaires et je ne suis
pas une exception
l'immense majorité de l'aîné collègues a
choisi ce métier pour cela mais cet
argument
cet argument de de la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire
mais honnêtement il ne vaut mieux en
rire parce que si l'on va en pleurer il
suffit de regarder que tous les
éditorialistes regarde les chiffres les
moyens alloués à la lutte contre le
décrochage scolaire depuis que monsieur
blanc caire ministre est bien une viron
qu'elles font il est fondu comme neige
au soleil
j'ai des années sur votre antenne ces
chiffres là donc cet argument l'iss est
en réalité un argument fallacieux
la seule raison c'est encore une fois
qu'il s'agit de faciliter le retour à
l'activité économique des paroles donc
on se dit que gagner dix jours d'école
c'est gagner dix jours de garderie sous
la question de la lutte contre les
inégalités c'est est l'alpha et l'oméga
de ce gouvernement
eh bien on n'aurait pas mis l'exemple
par exemple on pourrait s'intéresser à
la façon dont on s'intéresse aux parents
il ya un dispositif ya des dispositifs
mis en place qui vont consister à
baisser la rémunération du chômage
partiel alors qu'on était déjà à 84% ya
le fameux dispositif de larmes qui va
effectivement faire baisser à 70 % la
rémunération des salariés
ce gouvernement il s'intéresse à la
lutte contre les inégalités comme les
confiseurs comme les confiseurs lutte
contre les caries et il s'agit d'
arrêter de prendre les gens pour des
idiots en leur disant qu en dix jours on
va lutter contre les inégalités
scolaires
il va falloir rattraper effectivement il
est vrai qu'on a perdu des élèves
pendant deux mois
et qu'est ce qui va se passer eh bien
les prendre vont mettre les bouchées
doubles en septembre et c'est comme ça
qu'on va le régler et c'est les profs
qui vont s'en charger certainement pas
monsieur blanc terre et sa pseudo
on prend les inégalités scolaires
benjamin marveaux par les économies le
président évoquait la préco vie d'un
longuement et la reconstruction
économique du pays chômage partiel des
entreprises dans tous les secteurs
l'état a mis près au rappel de 500
milliards d'euros sur la table ces trois
derniers mois je vous propose d'écouter
cet extrait d' emmanuel macron ces
dépenses se justifier et se justifie en
raison des circonstances exceptionnelles
que nous venons de vivre
mais elles viennent s'ajouter à notre
dette déjà existantes
nous ne financerons pas ses dépenses en
augmentant les impôts notre pays est
déjà l'un de ceux où la fiscalité est la
plus lourde
même si depuis trois ans nous avons
commencé à l'abaisser
la seule réponse est de bâtir un modèle
économique durable plus fort de travail
et de produire davantage pour ne pas
dépendre des autres alors pas
d'augmentation d'impôts promet emmanuel
macron denis demonpion peut-on le croire
pour écouter les paroles et promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les profèrent le
spa il on ne voit pas comment le
président de la république un moment
donné
pourra parcourir sinon à l'impôt direct
ce que faisait très bien françois
hollande son prédécesseur lui avait
choisi depuis qu'il est président de la
république un autre biais c'est à dire
d'augmenter les taxes
donc on ne voit pas le l'endettement de
la france à continuer éternellement même
si les critères de maastricht ont été
mis momentanément mis entre parenthèses
un moment donné il faudra payer
l'addition
comment si le président de la république
fait le pari que l'économie va repartir
et la croissance aussi c'est loin d'être
acquis puisque on le voit bien depuis le
déconfinement le 11 mai et bien
l'activité a été très difficile à
reprendre
il ya toujours d'abord le virus n'est
pas vaincu donc et on ne sait pas si
demain il ne va pas à nouveau être d'une
virulence qui va obliger à prendre des
mesures drastiques en main du point de
vue sanitaire
donc de ce point de vue là il ya
toujours une espèce d'hésitation mais il
est vrai aussi que l'économie a été mise
totalement à plat et le chômage partiel
qui a été effectivement en europe le
plus comment dirais-je le plus large qui
soit puisque aucun autre pays en europe
à favoriser ce système à ce point là il
ya eu quand je lui rappelle quand même
12 millions de français ont bénéficié de
ça un moment donné il faut payer
l'addition
le président de la république a souligné
hier que tout ça n'empêcherait pas des
faillites des licenciements
donc il est devant un mur il n'a pas ses
vrais apporter de réponse à la manière
de faire face à ce mur et de l'escaladé
et il a juste exhorté les français
une fois encore à retrousser leurs
manches mais encore faut-il que
ils retroussent leurs manches dans un
contexte un petit peu plus précis que
celui qui a été dessiné hier notamment
en matière industrielle
quand il a parlé de rapatrier ou de
développer certains secteurs industriels
pardonnez moi de vous couper parce que
c'est un débat benjamin a marre sur
cette réponse d'emmanuel l'écran est
votre interlocuteur également bon
d'abord première chose on se rend bien
compte quand même que les libéraux
avaient tort parce que effectivement on
a eu en france le choix de d'impliquer
l'état dans l'économie
à un niveau inédit donc ce qui prouve
bien que quand ça tangue
quand effectivement le navire est en
train de tanguay et bien c'est
l'intervention de l'état ce qui notre
bien que le système libéral et d'une
vacuité s'en faut maintenant attention
parce que si on nous refait le même coup
qu'en 2008
on a eu une intervention massive de
l'état dans l'économie mais qu'ensuite
on a fait payer aux salariés et bien
quelque part c'est un véritable scandale
si l'on veut que le jour d'après ne
ressemble pas au jour d'avant empire
il faut réfléchir aux solutions parce
que encore une facture responsables de
la crise
ces prix elle a été provoquée encore une
fois par un système libéral qui
s'attaque aux ressources du vivant qui
saccagent les services publics et le
service public hospitalier a failli être
débordée qui affaiblit notre puissance
industrielle par des délocalisations
donc si on dit aux salariés c'est vous
qui allez payer les pots cassés alors
qu'ils ne sont responsables en rien de
celles prises
ça ne passera pas je rappelle que la
situation sociale est explosive et le
gouvernement le sait on n'a même pas
besoin de lui répéter
alors quand on entend la petite phrase
il va falloir travailler et produire
davantage et que l'on sait que depuis
plusieurs semaines les vautours léa
certain nombre de vautours avec une
mentalité de charognards ils disent
qu'il faut travailler pis si c'est ça le
sens de cette phrase sibylline
consistant à dire il faut produire et
travailler davantage
alors on gouvernement doit savoir qu'il
est assis sur un baril de poudre
la cgtr frisera refusera catégoriquement
que l'on baisse les salaires
ou que l'on augmente le temps de travail
les accords de performance collective
qui sont mises en place et qui consiste
effectivement à faire baisser les
salaires avec un chantage insupportable
à l'emploi je peux vous garantir qu'on
va en faire une bataille cruciale
il y a des solutions il y a deux
solutions je veux dire on a toujours
pourquoi ce gouvernement ne décide pas
c'est le moment ou jamais de mener une
bataille nationale contre l'évasion
fiscale
y'en a des milliards à rattraper joe
rappelle qu'alors qu'on nous dit que le
cac 40 est en berne est en hibernation
je rappelle que axa qui refusent de
rembourser les restes et restaurateurs
et les commerçants qui ont été confinés
distribuer 1,7 milliard de dividendes
aux actionnaires total 7 milliards
sanofi 4 milliards donc encore une fois
si on veut s'occuper de la fiscalité n'y
a pas de problème on peut augmenter la
fiscalité pour mettre en place une
fiscalité sur les dividendes une
taxation
une manière de taxer enfin le le le
capital financier
il ya de quoi faire le bois de la barge
merci en tout cas tous les deux on
arrive déjà à la fin de ce débat il ya
plusieurs thèmes qu'on voulait aborder
mais voilà en tout cas vous vous avez
donné votre opinion sur les grandes
mesures merci benjamin marc denis deux
montants d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france